>> Greg: I AM GREG GUTFELD
WITH KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS AND
MELISSA BRANSON.
"THE FIVE" ."
WELL, SOMEONE IS SPOILING FOR A
FIGHT.
>> WHEN THE GUY WHO ENDED UP
BEING OUR NATIONAL LEADERS THAT
I CAN GRAB A WOMAN ANYWHERE AND
SHE LIKES IT, THEY ASKED ME WHAT
I LIKE TO DEBATE THIS GENTLEMAN
COME I SAID NO, IF WE WERE IN
HIGH SCHOOL, I WOULD TAKE HIM
BEHIND THE GYM AND BEAT THE HELL
OUT OF HIM.
>> Greg: I WOULD KICK YOUR IF
I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
BIDEN WAS SPEAKING AT A RALLY
AGAINST SEXUAL ASSAULT.
HIS MESSAGE, TO URGE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MEN AND
WOMEN.
BUT NO ONE CARES NOW BECAUSE
WE'VE GOT A FIGHT ON OUR HAND.
WELCOME DIES GO WHERE THE BIG
MAN ON CAMPUS TO TAUNT EACH
OTHER AND EVERYONE GATHERS TO
WATCH.
THE COMBINED AGE IS 150.
IF THERE IS GOING TO BE A
TUSSLE, YOU'RE GOING TO NEED FIX
IT END -- FIXODENT.
IT'S ALWAYS THE PEOPLE WHO BOAST
ABOUT THEIR PHYSICAL PROWESS ARE
THE LEAST POWERFUL.
IT WAS A WEEK AGO THAT THE
DEMOCRATS WERE FRETTING OVER
WHETHER THEY HAD A FIGHTER AMONG
THEM TO MATCH TRUMP.
IT IS THE LEAST APPEALING PART
OF TRUMP'S BEHAVIOR AND IT IS SO
FAKE.
PLUS THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER GOOD
STUFF.
THE RALLIES, THE SUPPORT FOR
LONG ORDER, THE STRONG STANCE
AGAINST TERROR.
BUT TO FOCUS ON THE ONE THING
MOST PEOPLE INCLUDING TRUMP
SUPPORTERS ONLY REALLY TOLERATE
BECAUSE OF THE OTHER GOOD STUFF
TRUMP POSSESSES, THAT'S A
MISCALCULATION.
AND IT'S ONE REPUBLICANS LOVE TO
SEE BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE ARE
REALLY BAD AT BEING TRUMP EXCEPT
TRUMP.
ALL RIGHT, JESSE.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF JOE BIDEN'S
TOUGH TALK.
YOU THINK IT'S AUTHENTIC OR
WEIRD?
>> Jesse: I THINK IT IS
AUTHENTICALLY WEIRD.
THAT IS HOW BIDEN HAS ALWAYS
BEEN.
HE'S KIND OF ALWAYS BEEN A JOKE.
HE WAS POLLING AT 1% OF THE
PRIMARY.
OBAMA NEEDED A WHITE MALE WITH
EXPERIENCE IN THE SWAMP TO KIND
OF OFFSET OBAMA WHO WAS FRESH
AND YOUNG HIS NAME LOOKED GOOD
ON A BUMPER STICKER.
THE GUY WAS NOT A CONSEQUENTIAL
VP COMPARED TO DICK CHENEY OR
BUSH 41.
CAN YOU IMAGINE SPEAKING OF
DICK CHENEY, IF HE HAD SAID HE
WAS GOING TO TAKE OBAMA TO THE
SCHOOLYARD AND BEAT HIM UP?
IT WOULD BE ALL OVER THE PLACE
BUT THE LEFT CAN GET AWAY WITH
THE STUFF.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING TRUMP CYBER
BULLIED THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT.
PEOPLE NEED TO GET OVER THAT.
THIS MIGHT BE HIS FIRST FORAY
INTO RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
I DON'T SEE THE DEMOCRATS
NOMINATING STRAIGHT WHITE MALE.
I THINK THEY ARE TOO HANDCUFFED
BY IDENTITY POLITICS.
THIS IS JUST JOE BEING JOE.
HE LOWERED HIMSELF INTO THE
GUTTER HERE.
IF BIDEN WANTS TO BE A STATESMAN
AND WANTS TO RISE ABOVE IT AND
BE THE OLDER GUY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, GETTING IN THE
GUTTER WITH DONALD TRUMP IS NOT
GOOD FOR YOUR BRAND, AND YOU ARE
GOING TO LOSE.
>> Greg: KIMBERLY, I BELIEVE
WE HAVE TAPE OF MR. BIDEN
GETTING READY TO CHALLENGE
TRUMP.
DO WE HAVE THAT TAPE?
>> Jesse: BIGGER WITS.
>> Greg: I WAS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION JOE WAS GOING TO BE
THE NICE GUY.
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
OPPOSITE OF TRUMP.
>> Kimberly: UNCLE JOE.
BECAUSE YOU WANT FUZZY BACK RUBS
WHO
AND MASSAGES ON YOUR SHOULDERS.
THOSE ARE PART OF UNCLE JOE.
LET'S REFRESH OUR RECOLLECTION.
WITH THOSE WATER WEIGHTS?
ONE TIME A GUY DID THAT, WHILE,
YOU ARE LIFTING A LOT.
IT HAD WATER IN IT.
I WOULD PUT MY MONEY.
>> Jesse: MAYBE GIVE HIM A
GOLF CLUB.
>> Greg: JUAN, THAT'S A GOOD
IDEA.
PAY-PER-VIEW CHARITY FIGHT.
YOU COULD HAVE A UNDERCARD
FEATURING JOHN KERRY AND JIM
CARREY.
>> Juan: THIS IS, TO ME, HOW
LOW CAN YOU GO?
MICHELLE OBAMA SAID THIS THING
ABOUT WHEN THEY GO LOW, WE GO
HIGH.
I DON'T THINK JOE BIDEN WAS
FOLLOWING THAT.
>> Greg: HE GETS HIGH.
>> Juan: IN RESPONSE TO THE
KIND OF OFFENSIVE RHETORIC THAT
COMES FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DON'T FORGET.
PEOPLE THOUGHT YOU KNOW WHAT?
HE'S GOING TO BE PRESIDENTIAL.
HE'S GOING TO STRAIGHTEN HIS ACT
UP.
HE'S NEVER STRAIGHTENED HIS ACT
HIS RESPONSE TO JOE BIDEN WAS TO
PUT JOE BIDEN DOWN, CALL HIM
"CRAZY JOE."
>> Kimberly: A LOT OF PEOPLE
DO THAT.
>> Juan: THAT'S NOT FAIR TO
JOE.
LOOK AT THE RECORD.
JOE BIDEN WAS HEAD OF SENATE
JUDICIARY.
DID A GREAT JOB, WIDELY
RESPECTED IN TERMS OF FOREIGN
POLICY CREDENTIALS.
>> Jesse: NO, HE'S NOT, JUAN.
HE IS NOT WIDELY RESPECTED.
>> Juan: NIGHT TO BREAK IT TO
YOU.
>> Jesse: HE WAS AGAINST THE
BIN LADEN RAID.
>> Juan: THAT'S FINE.
A LOT OF AMERICANS THINK THAT
WAS A MISTAKE.
>> Kimberly: BIN LADEN DEAD?
>> Juan: IRAQ.
>> Kimberly: THERE IS ONE
PERSON LIVING ON REGRET ISLAND
AND ITS BIN LADEN.
>> Juan: YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND HE WAS SAYING TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA LET'S BE CAREFUL
ABOUT WHAT WE ARE DOING.
WHAT YOU ARE DOING IS TRYING TO
BELITTLE BIDEN AND I DON'T THINK
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE BUY IT.
>> BIDEN IS THE ONE WHO
BELITTLED BIDEN.
ALL THESE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
CRITICIZED PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR
THE WAY HE CONDUCTS HIMSELF AND
THEY TURN AROUND AND THEY NEED
HIM RIGHT DOWN ON THAT LEVEL.
THEY TALK ABOUT HITTING HIM.
THIS WAS A RALLY THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT SEXUAL
ASSAULT ON WOMEN.
AND YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN OUT THERE
SAYING THINGS LIKE IF I HAD BEEN
IN -- I'VE BEEN IN LOCKER ROOMS.
I'M A PRETTY GOOD ATHLETE.
THE GUY WHO TALKED THAT WAY WAS
USUALLY THE FATTEST, UGLIEST SLB
IN THE ROOM.
IS THIS HOW YOU TALK?
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT
SEXUAL ASSAULT ON WOMEN AND HE
GOES WAY OFF ON THIS TANGENT.
BY THE WAY, HIS ATTITUDE ABOUT
THE WHOLE -- NOT EVERYTHING
GOING ON IN THE ME TOO MOVEMENT.
SO MANY WOMEN LOOK AT THIS AS
PERPETUATING THIS IDEA OF WOMEN
AS VICTIMS.
HE IS SAYING THEN, YOU HAVE TO
STAND UP AND STOP OTHER MEN FROM
ASSAULTING WOMEN.
AND WOMEN, YOU'VE GOT TO GET
YOUR FRIENDS AND TAKE THEM HOME.
HE IS IN THE DARK AGES WITH THIS
SPEECH ON EVERY SINGLE LEVEL.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING
FOR A CANDIDATE.
TALKING ABOUT BIDEN, THIS COULD
BE THE START FOR 2020.
>> Kimberly: THEY HAVE NO ONE
ELSE LEFT.
>> Juan: I THINK PEOPLE ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE ARE CONFUSED BY
THE FACT THAT TRUMP IS SO
COMBATIVE AND HE USES SUCH HARSH
LANGUAGE, CONDEMNING LANGUAGE.
HE SAID IN RESPONSE, HE CALLED
BIDEN "MENTALLY AND PHYSICALLY
WEAK."
DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING FOR
SOMEBODY WHO CAN STAND UP TO
TRUMP.
I THINK THAT'S PART OF WHAT
JOE BIDEN IS DOING, SAYING HEY,
I'M IN HERE.
I'M GOING TO FIGHT.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT WOMEN, DON'T
FORGET THE REASON HE IS SAYING
THIS IS NOT -- I DON'T GET THAT
POINT FROM YOU.
HE IS SAYING WHEN TRUMP TALKS
ABOUT GRABBING WOMEN ANYWHERE,
HE THINKS IT'S WRONG, OFFENSIVE.
MEN DO NOT TALK THAT WAY IN
LOCKER ROOMS.
I THINK BY THE WAY, THAT'S TRUE,
MELISSA.
>> Melissa: HE IS SAYING THAT
MEN NEED TO STAND UP AND PROTECT
WOMEN AND I DON'T THINK YOUNG
WOMEN TODAY WANT UNCLE JOE BIDEN
OUT THERE PROTECTING THEM.
I THINK THEY FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES
AND THAT'S WHAT HE IS MISSING.
SAYING REAL MEN DON'T DO THIS
AND REAL MEN GET OUT THERE AND
PROTECT WOMEN.
IT IS THE SAME, YOU ARE TALKING
DOWN TO WOMEN IN A WAY THAT JUST
MISSES WHAT THEY ARE LOOKING
FOR.
>> Greg: YOU ARE SAYING
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO FIND THE
FEISTY COUNTERPART.
THE PROBLEM IS, THAT'S NOT GOING
TO BE THE SOLUTION.
IF YOU TRY -- WE SAW THIS WITH
MARCO RUBIO.
IF YOU TRY TO OUT TRUMP TRUMP,
IT'S NOT WHO YOU REALLY ARE.
LIKE BIDEN, BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S WHO HE REALLY IS.
I THINK ANYBODY WHO TRIES TO DO
THE TRUMP THING IS PROBABLY
GOING TO LOSE BECAUSE TRUMP DOES
IT BETTER.
>> Jesse: JOHN KERRY, THEY
NOMINATED HIM WHEN BUSH WAS
RUNNING FOR REELECTION DURING
THE HEIGHT OF THE IRAQ WAR AND
HE PLAYED UP HIS VIETNAM SERVICE
EVEN THOUGH JOHN KERRY WAS
INFAMOUS FOR DENIGRATING A LOT
OF THE VIETNAM WAR VETERANS WHEN
THEY CAME HOME, SAYING THEY CUT
OFF EARS AND SAID ALL THAT
HORRIBLE STUFF.
I DIDN'T PASS THE SMELL TEST FOR
A LOT OF AMERICANS.
VOTERS SMELL INAUTHENTICITY.
LIKE WE SAID IN THE BEGINNING,
IS THIS REALLY THE REAL JOE?
KIMBERLY HITS IT ON THE HEAD.
WE LIKE JOE BECAUSE HE'S ON
AMTRAK AND HE'S UNCLE JOE
ANNIE'S -- AND HE'S AW, SHUCKS.
THE TOUGH GUY WHO'S GOING TO
TAKE TRUMP OUT, PEOPLE DON'T BUY
IT.
>> Kimberly: HE CAN'T DO
TRUMP.
IT IS LIKE THE GEORGE FOREMAN
GRILL.
THERE'S REALLY ONLY ONE.
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
IMITATIONS, A LOT A LOT OF
ATTEMPTS TO TRY TO MASTER THE
GEORGE FOREMAN GRILL.
POTUS IS THE GEORGE FOREMAN
GRILL.
>> Greg: DO YOU STILL USE YOUR
GRILL?
>> Kimberly: I LOVE IT.
LAMB CHOPS, STEAK, FISH,
VEGETABLES.
>> Greg: I THINK THEY HAVE A
NEW SPOKESPERSON.
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW IF